[Música]
el expresidente estadounidense Donald
Trump advirtió que sería arrestado Este
martes y llamó a sus seguidores a
protestar el ex mandatario no precisó el
motivo de su presunto arresto pero sus
declaraciones se dan en medio de las
audiencias por el supuesto pago a una
actriz de películas para adultos
El Vaticano cerró su embajada en la
capital nicaragüense y su representante
tuvo que salir del país hacia Costa Rica
la medida se da luego de una escalada
verbal entre ambos estados agudizada por
la persecución del gobierno de Daniel
Ortega a la iglesia católica
masivas movilizaciones se llevaron a
cabo en toda Francia luego de que el
gobierno aprobara la reforma a las
pensiones se someter el proyecto a
votación de la asamblea nacional en
París decenas de miles de personas Se
tomaron las calles y se registraron
choques con la policía
Hola Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en France 24 los saluda Andrés
Meza Muñoz empezamos en Estados Unidos
el expresidente Donald Trump vuelve a
estar en el centro de la actualidad
después de regresar a Facebook y YouTube
publicó un su red social trees social
que una filtración le informó que será
arrestado el martes al parecer por los
pagos con fondos de la campaña de 2016 a
la actriz stormy Daniels a cambio de su
silencio y animó a sus seguidores a
protestar contra la detención y a
recuperar la nación lluís Muñoz con los
detalles
tormenta Trump el expresidente dijo en
su red social red social que podría ser
arrestado el martes un mensaje que
recordó al que precedió al asalto al
Capitolio ahora filtraciones ilegales de
una corrupta y altamente politizada
oficina del fiscal de Manhattan que ha
permitido que se establezcan nuevos
récords de crímenes violentos y cuyo
líder está financiado por George soros
indican que sin que se pueda aprobar
ningún Crimen y basándose en un viejo y
totalmente desacreditado por numerosos
otros Fiscales Cuento de hadas el
candidato republicano más importante y
el expresidente de los Estados Unidos de
América será arrestado el martes de la
próxima semana protestas recuperen
nuestra nación un gran Jurado de Nueva
York que Investiga los presuntos pagos
de Trump durante la campaña de 2016 para
silenciar a la actriz porno estormy
Daniels y a la modelo de Playboy Karen
mcdual por un total de 280 mil dólares
pagos registrados como gastos legales
sería el primer ex presidente en ser
acusado de un delito esto podría afectar
carrera presidencial
el Cardo que puede presentar El fiscal y
que parece que está a punto de presentar
es que Trump falsificó los registros
comerciales de la organización Trump lo
cual es criminal en Nueva York si
falsifica los registros comerciales de
una empresa comercial Entonces está
sujeto a una sanción de al menos seis
meses eso es un delito menor pero si lo
hace para ocultar otro delito Entonces
se convierte en un delito grave y eso
puede darte una sentencia de hasta 4
años que es un impacto mucho mayor
Trump también enfrenta investigaciones
criminales en Atlanta y Washington por
sus esfuerzos para revertir los
resultados en 2020 también se investigan
los documentos clasificados encontrados
en el domicilio del ex mandatario en
Florida
el estado de Wyoming en Estados Unidos
prohibió las píldoras para abortar el
gobernador republicano MC Gordon
promulgó el viernes el proyecto de ley
que declara ilegal recetar dispensar
distribuir vender o usar los
medicamentos abortivos la norma excluye
los tratamientos que se necesiten para
proteger las mujeres cuya vida y salud
estén en peligro inminente pero para el
resto de personas que usan la píldora
para abortar podrán estar hasta seis
meses en la cárcel y pagar multas de
hasta nueve mil dólares
el presidente del banco interamericano
de desarrollo instó al organismo hacer
mucho más por el desarrollo de América
Latina con un nuevo plan centrado en
temas sociales el clima y la integración
regional sus declaraciones se dieron
desde ciudad de Panamá donde se celebra
la edición número 63 de la asamblea del
Beat y de la que participan varios
ministros de finanzas economía y a otros
altos funcionarios de los países
miembros la ampliación de esta noticia
desde la capital panameña con nuestro
corresponsal Oscar zulurán
este sábado se inauguró oficialmente la
reunión de gobernadores del banco
interamericano de desarrollo la primera
en forma presencial tras la pandemia
ministros de finanzas a presidentes de
banco centrales directivos de bancos de
todo el mundo se hicieron presentes y
todo esto coincide con la turbulencia
bancaria de los últimos días en Estados
Unidos y Europa si bien la región creció
3.9% el último año en este momento
existe una desaceleración que preocupa a
los sectores presentes en este encuentro
en Ciudad de Panamá a causas según ilean
goldfine presidente del Beat responden a
la guerra en Ucrania deudas más altas de
los gobiernos la inflación también con
altos niveles inseguridad alimentaria y
energética Además del cambio climático
Dentro de este panorama dice golfine que
América Latina puede representar una
solución en el mundo por ejemplo cree
que la región puede producir ocho veces
más alimento de lo que produce en la
actualidad también destacó que el 30% de
la energía que se produce en la región
es de fuentes renovables y que además
esa cifra aumenta a 80% cuando se habla
América Central la reunión de
gobernadores del bit continuará este
domingo habrá una sesión plenaria Y por
último un comunicado en el que se
informarán los acuerdos alcanzados en
este encuentro en Ciudad de Panamá El
Vaticano anunció el cierre de su
embajada en Nicaragua a petición del
gobierno de Daniel Ortega luego de la
escalada diplomática entre ambos estados
que se extendió durante semanas tras la
medida al representante de la santa sede
salió de territorio nicaragüense hacia
Costa Rica para el análisis saludamos en
Bogotá a Hernán olano él es vaticanista
y doctor en derecho canónico señor olano
Bienvenido a France 24 es muy inusual
que en este caso una ciudad estado como
el Vaticano cierre su embajada en otro
país Qué significa esto para la santa
sede
sí efectivamente Andrés son Trece ya
catorce con Nicaragua los países que no
mantienen relaciones con la santa sede
dentro de ellos algunos países
musulmanes como butanas Afganistán
Arabia Saudita países comunistas como
china Corea del Norte lados o Vietnam
pero este es el único país americano un
país de un arraigambre católica que sin
embargo de acuerdo con lo dicho por el
papa Hace algunos días en cuanto a una
dictadura grosera para calificar el
régimen nicaragüense ellos le
notificaron al secretario de la embajada
que debía cerrarse esta representación
diplomática ya desde marzo del año
pasado el arzobispo sommertag un
Valdemar está en islam summertec polaco
había abandonado precisamente Nicaragua
porque había participado como observador
en las elecciones de 2021 y venían
trabajando con la oea como observador
y participe en la mesa de diálogo con la
oposición desde el año 2018 esto pues
hace que realmente de acuerdo con la
convención de Viena sobre relaciones
diplomáticas y consulares la embajada
quede a su suerte aunque se le ha
encomendado al gobierno por parte del
gobierno
italiano
a su embajador el que cuide de esa
representación diplomática que se
encuentra allí entonces en este momento
sin cabeza debido a que monseñor Marcel
nigeriano secretario de la embajada pues
ha sido despedido por el embajador de la
Unión Europea y Los Embajadores de
Alemania Italia y Francia el día de ayer
quedando ya de esa manera acéfala esa
representación en Managua ahora sin El
Vaticano haciendo presencia en Nicaragua
que puede pasar por ejemplo con casos
como el del monseñor Rolando Álvarez
quien fue condenado allí tras sus
críticas al gobierno y además se negó a
abandonar el país
sí efectivamente cuando no hay
relaciones del Vaticano con Alguna algún
país Entonces no puede nombrar un
delegado apostólico que únicamente
cuidará de los intereses de la santa
sede pero lo que tiene que ver
precisamente con solicitud omnio
eclesial la Constitución Apostólica de
1969 Pablo sexto en torno a las materias
que debe trabajar un anuncio estarían
bastante restringidas y únicamente esa
figura si se diera estaría dedicada a lo
apostólico y no podría intervenir en lo
político que tiene que ver precisamente
con estas circunstancias de expulsión
que se ha venido dando de religiosas
religiosos y sacerdotes y la condena de
los veintiséis años al obispo de matagal
bien y finalmente señor olano sienta
este un este caso un precedente para que
otros países en los que la Iglesia
Católica ha sido crítica tomen medidas
similares contra El Vaticano
planteamiento lateral del gobierno de
Managua no obstante que existieron
también unas frases un poco
desobligantes de acuerdo con ese
gobierno por parte del Papa como cabeza
de la iglesia hacia
lo que representa el señor Ortega y toda
su familia entonces podrían darse
circunstancias similares como ya ocurrió
también un poco de tensión por ejemplo
en Venezuela que no ha llegado a
cerrarse la embajada y de la cual el
actual Secretario de estado del Vaticano
monseñor Pietro parolín fue anuncio en
ese país y por esa razón tal vez se
conservan una cierta relaciones
distantes pero cordiales bien era Hernán
olano vaticanista y doctor en derecho
canónico Gracias por acompañarnos con el
análisis aquí en France 24 con mucho
gusto Andrés y seguimos con noticias
América Latina al menos 13 muertos dejó
un terremoto de magnitud 6.5 en Ecuador
el epicentro tuvo lugar en Guayaquil y
también se sintió en Perú la presidencia
ecuatoriana indicó en un comunicado que
unas 126 personas resultaron heridas y
descartó la advertencia de un posible
tsunami el presidente Guillermo lasso
dijo que su gobierno activó todos los
protocolos para atender a los
damnificados e iniciar la reconstrucción
de las viviendas que resultaron
afectadas
este sábado kiev y Moscú gracias a la
mediación de Turquía y la ONU acordaron
prolongar el acuerdo que permite
exportar granos desde los puertos del
mar Negro Aunque el nuevo plazo no de
vigencia no está claro el acuerdo
expiraba Esta media noche y según Rusia
se ha prolongado por 60 días mientras
que Ucrania aseguró que será por los
próximos cuatro meses
un carguero lleno de trigo cruza el
bósforo una transacción posible gracias
al acuerdo firmado por rusos y
ucranianos el pasado mes de julio este
compromiso conocido como la iniciativa
del mar Negro ha permitido exportar
desde Ucrania más de 24 millones de
toneladas de cereales
exportaciones vitales para aliviar la
crisis alimentaria mundial
es extremadamente importante que la
iniciativa del mar Negro siga
funcionando no solo para continuar el
comercio eficiente del grano a través
del mar Negro hoy sino también para la
próxima cosecha y la próxima temporada
Necesitamos poder seguir teniendo el
flujo de grano necesario para
estabilizar el mercado
Moscú propuso prorrogar el acuerdo dos
meses más el texto original firmado bajo
los auspicios de Turquía permitía una
prórroga de 120 días sin embargo desde
las partes mediadoras no se ha
especificado la duración de la
ampliación del acuerdo Aunque Ucrania
sostiene que es por cuatro meses Rusia
por dos
negociación Rusia negocia para obtener
facilidades para sus propias
exportaciones
Por otra parte Rusia no quiere que se
considere que bloquea las exportaciones
de los países al sur que necesitan esos
cereales
una segunda parte de la iniciativa se
refería a las exportaciones de
fertilizantes antes de la guerra y las
sanciones
Moscú enviaba fertilizantes a todo el
mundo hoy más de 260.000 toneladas de
fertilizantes rusos están bloqueadas en
los puertos europeos al kremlin le
gustaría poder reanudar este comercio
con normalidad a pesar de las sanciones
económicas las autoridades ucranianas
agradecieron el sábado a las Naciones
Unidas y a Turquía la prórroga del
acuerdo de granos
vamos a Francia en las calles de
diferentes ciudades como París nantes o
burdeos miles de personas se
manifestaron en contra del presidente
Manuel macron y la forma en como impuso
su reforma pensional saltándose la
votación del proyecto de la asamblea
nacional según el gobierno el aumento en
la edad de jubilación de 62 a 64 años
que también enoja los franceses evitaría
que el sistema quiebre Andrés granadillo
tiene más
arde París tras las fuertes protestas
contra la reforma pensional de macrón
que subirá de los 62 a los 64 años la
edad de jubilación el presidente utilizó
el artículo 49.3 que deja El Ejecutivo
la potestad de aprobar proyectos de ley
sin necesidad de pasarlos por el
legislativo
la gente se mantiene unida Estados
Unidos contra esta reforma al menos una
mayoría de los franceses y no
escucharnos no dejar que nuestros
diputados ni siquiera voten es una
negación de democracia es despreciable
despreciable al señor macron no escucha
que los franceses están en las calles no
escuchan
No estoy nada de acuerdo mi hijo que
hizo sus estudios no quiero que trabaje
hasta los 67 años 68 años ya que tendrá
que haber hecho 176 trimestres tú haces
tus cuentas Ya verás
la Popular reforma pensional ha desatado
la ira de una gran parte de la sociedad
francesa en antes al oeste de Francia
hubo una manifestación que inició de
manera pacífica y que terminó en
enfrentamientos con la policía
antidisturbios Asimismo en la edad
manifestantes participaron en una marcha
intersindical no tan lejos los
trabajadores de la refinería de petróleo
total Energy detuvieron la producción el
viernes aunque ya este sábado se
restableció el acceso al por su parte el
gobierno de macron considera sustancial
la reforma para evitar que el sistema
quiebre además alinearía a Francia con
otros países europeos donde la edad de
jubilación es más alta
otras manifestaciones también se
registraron en Portugal que como en gran
parte del mundo el aumento del costo de
vida también causa estragos entre la
población convocados por el principal
sindicato del país miles de trabajadores
salieron a marchar en las calles de la
capital Lisboa para exigir aumentos
salariales y de las pensiones así como
límites al precio de los productos
básicos mientras la inflación interanual
fue del 8,2% en febrero el incremento
del costo de las frutas y verduras fue
del 20% sin embargo el ministro de
economía del gobierno liderado por el
socialista Antonio Acosta rechazó La
regulación
hasta que este informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]